Kids
killing kids.
It's not fun and so desensitizes what we have to do because that is hard
job.
It's a job.
Okay,
excellent.
The other wall this size,
the notes here,
brainwashing was it sold?
Oh Wow.
Um,
I don't think the natural inclination for a human being is to want to kill
another human being.
There is a necessary requirement in the military to get you to perform a certain
action and in order for that action to occur,
it is my theory that there is a part of changing the way that you think in order
to take somebody from a human being and make it a target so that you can achieve
a goal.
Everybody else,
come on.
Faye had asked our,
our,
the military,
um,
desensitizing soldiers,
are they manipulating them mentally?
And I would have walked over here.
I would have walked over here to brainwashing.
Has It?
Well,
I dunno man.
It's just like,
I even watch like the advertisements for the military and it just seems to me
the one thing you brought up was,
was killing.
Um,
it's,
no,
no one wants to do it.
I know.
I don't want to do it.
I know I didn't want to flip too.
If you have used the words desensitize,
we're desensitizing yourself because we have to.
We have to move on.
And just think that,
that's kind of my point though,
in order to get from that spot where you don't want to kill another human being
to where you look at it as,
this is just my job,
but it's a choice.
It's not brainwashed and really just comes down to it.
And that guy at the end of your muscle or you.
Right.
And I want to come back home to my family
war is a necessary,
are you?
Ah,
okay.
This is a tough one.
I think that there's a point between a just war and an unjust war.
There are certain wars that um,
you know,
maybe we should have gone into like maybe we shouldn't have gone an entire rack.
Right,
right.
And then there are certain wars were world war two,
you know,
where Hitler was advancing to Poland.
I think that's definitely a just war to get into.
And then he was trying to kill Jewish people.
Yeah.
And then that case,
you could call it a necessary evil or is it a time that that necessary evil has
to happen?
And in that you don't even maybe call it a necessary evil,
it's just a necessity.
The action itself has to take place.
Hmm.
As long as we leave this on the table at war's a necessary evil,
it really just excuses.
Almost all,
uh,
you know,
all wars.
Because if it's six,
the what's excusable,
right.
When does it become necessary?
If you really want to see what a peaceful world,
you have to just get rid of that cause they'll keyword there's is a necessary
necessary,
but I don't believe that.
I'm believe it's necessary that it's the only way for you to obtain your
objective is war.
That's the reason why I thought you were disagreeing with evil.
No,
no,
no.
I mean,
well,
yeah,
war is not evil.
I mean,
uh,
yeah,
it's,
it's not.
Um,
have you ever had an argument,
but you had good intentions course,
right?
So to speak on the word evil.
I don't really agree that war equals evil as well.
World peace is possible.
Oh,
sure.
Probable.
Maybe not possible.
Yes.
Yeah.
When you get humans together and find a way to find common ground to find the
similarities rather than the differences,
that's when you have a possibility at peace.
Now I believe that it is something that is possible on a grand scale.
Is it easy?
Maybe not,
but it is possible
world peace.
I want that to happen of course,
but it's so much easier said than done I think because just the way that we were
taught,
you know we all want world peace,
but let's say
where in Africa thinks that genital mutilation is perfectly fine?
Are we going to be perfectly fine with that?
Are we going to be able to talk them out of it?
I don't really think we are because they have their own customs,
their own culture.
So the only way we can kind of get them to accept our culture is through some
sort of violence that's dangerous.
Yeah.
I do believe the,
the quantum of people that would prefer piece to conflict is,
is growing.
And that's what gives me hope.
Yeah,
of course.
So if it meant if I die,
the world will be at peace.
Well,
yeah,
look,
I've,
I've had some amazing adventures on planet earth.
I've had the greatest of friends,
the greatest of families seem the best concerts.
Uh,
seen some beautiful places.
If it meant that that happened for this place to be a okay,
groovy.
Do it right now.
I had a good run.
I got 35 years.
That's than a lot.
Uh,
I've got more than twice.
Yeah.
Those years.
But more importantly,
I have two grandchildren and a third one on the way.
Yeah.
And really I had to think about it,
but if I could do that and bring them world peace,
let alone all the Lexi's and Charlie's around the world,
that's it.
Easy.
And like life is so beautiful.
But for me,
I believe there is a life after my life and there are many lifetimes.
Yeah.
If I had to die for world peace,
me versus 7 billion human beings,
like it's not even a question.
I initially,
when I heard the question,
I thought,
man,
what a dumb question.
And then Steve,
your answer actually really made me think like,
Oh wow,
actually elicited like a really beautiful response or you're talking about your
grandchildren,
you know,
and then I heard something that I am like,
I'll,
I'll think a little bit more about this question.
And I realized,
you know what if I say I'm willing to die for a piece?
Oh Gosh,
once the last time we did anything to actually promote peace,
so I'd be like,
wow,
I'd be really full of shit if I said that I would be willing to die repeat
piece.
I wouldn't be able to even take the most basic steps towards actually
contributing something basic.
Those basic steps totally matter.
Um,
but also living a life of purpose is a life that's lived a moment to moment to
moment.
So simply you,
by being you,
you affect people.
Like I,
I,
you see my around,
I only met you for what,
half an hour,
45 minutes.
You've got a good head on your shoulders and wherever you go,
you leave an imprint.
And that's true for all of us.
Yeah.
I mean,
don't get me wrong,
I don't want to die.
And I'd rather do those things.
I,
I'm in a,
I'm in a peace group that has met every Friday morning since nine 1116 years for
two hours every Friday to work on these issues.
So I think really if we,
oh,
I sometimes say a dollar a day and an hour a day,
I know someone who has died.
[inaudible]
yeah,
I know a lot of,
I mean,
not like tons of people,
but as you know,
dozen or so people we've had dug,
my closest friend who kill a was killed was a,
his name is Chris Domain and he had a wife and kids.
So it was a,
it's a pretty sad,
I've deployed seven times now and I'm scheduled to go back out in March.
Oh,
for my eighth back to Afghanistan.
But,
uh,
I think there was probably one or two deployments where we didn't lose someone.
Oh yeah.
I don't know if it's appropriate.
What taps into your courage to keep going back and the face of losing these
guys?
Yeah,
it's uh,
for me it's not only just a job.
When I say job,
I think of family.
I think I'm putting food on the table,
roof over the head of my family.
And then second to that are pretty much tied for first is the guys next to you.
You know,
I went to high school out here in La and really didn't have a future in college
or anything and just,
we grew up poor and homeless at some points,
but I joined the military,
wanted to serve my country and really just,
uh,
have some stable.
And as it evolved,
it was now it was like this big family,
you're part of,
you're part of something that's bigger.
And I don't mind,
uh,
deploying because I know I'm with family.
I think I'm blessed that I don't know anybody who's died in combat.
So I mean,
yeah,
I don't understand what you guys have been through,
but I applaud you,
all of you guys for,
like you said,
putting food on the table.
Because in my head I was like,
there's so many jobs up there.
Why this one?
When you're,
when you're a soldier,
you're,
you're making a sacrifice.
So thank you by the way.
You're welcome.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
I think
as Americans,
we appreciate anybody who makes us significant sacrifice.
That was kind of the ultimate sacrifice.
Yeah,
yeah.
No kidding.
So this,
this,
this exceeded my expectations.
I appreciate it.
That's pretty sure.
Yeah.
Okay.
Thank you for checking out that video.
Much appreciation.
Uh,
we get to do what we love because we all watch our videos.
So if you really love us,
you'll continue to keep watching videos.
There's more right here that you can check out.
You probably haven't seen all of them,
and if you really want to just commit to us,
you can subscribe right here.
I'll be around,
I'll be at the end of some more videos and I will keep in touch piece.